[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales en el
programa de france 24 que los invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas comenzamos
esta emisión en colombia país que acaba
de conmemorar 5 años desde la firma de
los acuerdos de paz entre el estado y la
guerrilla de las farc en 2016 cuando se
firmó el pacto el entonces presidente
juan manuel santos prometió que para
2021 ya no quedarían minas
antipersonales en el país esto ha sido
difícil de cumplir sin embargo con la
paz nacieron organizaciones como
humanicemos dh compuesta íntegramente
por desminadores ex combatientes de las
farc y nuestros periodistas luís muñoz y
aurora valle fueron a presenciar una de
esas operaciones
cuénteme don luís que por acá que como
encontrar un grupo de excombatientes de
las extintas farc ha encontrado un
artefacto pero podemos decir que que
puede ser una una mina antipersonal con
el campesino les había avisado de que en
su predio podría haber explosivos de la
guerra y no le subimos junto a sus
compañeros juan carlos prepara una
barricada que reduzca el daño
medioambiental
después mediante una bala de acero o van
a disparar contra el artefacto
listo vámonos
te hacen acá para que no para evitar
riesgos los desminadores se esconden
para todas la unidades y tiene la fuego
en un minuto
un riesgo donde una persona puede se
puede un animal se puede accidental lo
estamos quitando pues por eso estos
disparos son mejores que los que
hacíamos antes
fuego en el área
y
decíamos que no se crea contenedor será
no no lo haya visto alguna vez pero
puede ser sin seguir utilizaban como
contenedores de para hacer para fabricar
minas humanicemos es el resultado de los
acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno y la
guerrilla de las farc de 2016 aunque su
operación no empezó hasta 2020 reciben
financiación del fondo europeo para la
paz y su actividad está monitoreada por
un más el servicio de acción en contra
las minas de las naciones unidas tiene
más de 100 trabajadores y es la primera
organización de desminado del mundo
formada íntegramente por desminadores
firmantes de paz cada día se desplazan a
los remotos lugares que ocupaban cuando
eran combatientes de artefactos que
germán baranda es gerente de terreno en
las farc era comandante la
reincorporación trata de mantener las
estructuras anteriores con un fin muy
diferente fuimos un actor del conflicto
y que también colocamos minas hoy la
estamos retirando
la vuelta a la vida civil ha significado
una nueva oportunidad a la chica
cómo estás
[Música]
yo muy feliz en esta vida porque ya soy
una más con mi familia pero el impacto
del desminado también llega a las
comunidades en colombia cada día hay más
de una víctima por minas antipersonal
el área que se despejó el verdader ya
está volviendo a un resguardo de los
indígenas embera chamí apenas un mes
antes devolvieron el territorio libre de
minas podemos caminar en este es por
esta área es muy grato saber eso de
parte de ustedes que también agradecidos
y nosotros es también un desminado que
permite que los niños hoy puedan volver
a pisar los caminos de un futuro que
sueñan que sea de paz
la semana pasada un vuelo fletado por
las autoridades de bagdad permitió la
repatriación de más de 400 iraquíes que
duraron semanas varados en la frontera
entre belarús y polonia donde se vive
una verdadera crisis migratoria y
humanitaria nuestro equipo en ir acto al
encuentro de uno de estos repatriados y
nos trae su historia el siguiente es un
informe de luís ir was a man y olivia
aviso
en el primer vuelo de repatriación
iraquí desde minsk la semana pasada los
sueños rotos de los migrantes estaban
escritos en sus rostros
wissam fue uno de los migrantes que fue
repatriado el regreso fue difícil para
este joven iraquí que vendió casi todas
sus pertenencias en un intento de llegar
a polonia un intento que no tuvo éxito
al parecer el primer ministro va a
asignar dinero a través del departamento
de inmigración para facilitar la
obtención de préstamos para quienes han
regresado
en el ministerio ya no nos permitían
filmar nos reunimos con güiza min
nuevamente después de que hizo su
entrevista y envió su solicitud
espero que el gobierno encuentre la
solución es por ellos que la gente se va
porque crees que la gente huye porque
ves la situación en el país y piensas
que no hay esperanza no hay a las metas
no pueden dar y escapar
wissam pasó casi dos meses en la
frontera entre polonia y belarús en
condiciones extremas luego perdió la
esperanza y se regreso
tienes que aguantar el frío el hambre la
sed realmente pensé que lo lograría
lo intenté varias veces cruzar la
frontera y nunca funcionó
un total de 431 iraquíes regresaron a su
país de origen la semana pasada pero
miles más permanecen en belarús la
mayoría de ellos todavía esperan llegar
a la unión europea escapar de la crisis
económica y otras inestabilidad es en
irak
ante el avance de las tropas del frente
popular para la liberación del tigre
hacia adis abeba la capital del país
francia inició la evacuación de sus
ciudadanos desde etiopía el lunes
aterrizaron en el aeropuerto show de
gaulle de parís los primeros vuelos con
los repatriados y es que el conflicto
entre el gobierno del primer ministro
había ahmed y las milicias de la norteña
región del tigre se recrudeció
recientemente haciendo temer que la
guerra se propagara por todo el país el
siguiente es un informe de nuestros
enviados especiales a etiopía
[Música]
calma en las calles de addis abeba
la guerra civil en etiopía no ha llegado
a la capital pero los extranjeros como
el francés alexander que slayer están
haciendo las maletas
los 900 franceses que viven en la
capital fueron notificados por su
embajada tienen que irse ahora la
mayoría de las sedes diplomáticas
occidentales también han instado a sus
ciudadanos a regresar a sus países de
origen funden todos nuestros amigos se
han ido solo hay un puñado que se han
quedado porque tiene que hacerlo por su
trabajo o por elección fue en las
últimas semanas las fuerzas rebeldes del
tigre han avanzado por el país
capturando las ciudades de con bolsa y
se guardó vida a sólo 200 kilómetros de
la capital el primer ministro había
akhmed galardonado con el premio nobel
de la paz en 2019 se dirigió el martes
al frente de combate mientras llamaba a
los etíopes a defender el país
incluso antes de instar a la defensa
estas mujeres de la capital ya estaban
trabajando duro por el esfuerzo que
supone la guerra
estamos haciendo todo lo que podemos por
los soldados del gobierno estamos
preparando cebada además estamos donando
sangre para los militares también
donamos dinero para la causa el frente
de liberación popular del tigre lleva
más de un año de enfrentamientos con el
gobierno el que fuera un partido
gobernante se retiró al tigre cuando fue
expulsado del poder y ahora se unió al
ejército de liberación como otro grupo
rebelde en su avance hacia la capital a
principios de este mes un informe de las
naciones unidas- se reveló que los
civiles han sufrido la mayor parte de la
violencia de ambos bandos incluyendo
ataques indiscriminados
violaciones y desplazamientos forzados
así como miles de muertos el número
exacto es difícil de saber en medio de
un cierre continuo de internet y de los
servicios de comunicación en la región
los cristianos de sudán han podido vivir
con cierto alivio desde la caída del
dictador omar al bachir en el año 2019
durante su régimen estas comunidades
fueron discriminadas y sus templos
resultaron destruidos ahora tras el
golpe militar del pasado 25 de octubre
muchos temen que la situación para ellos
vuelva a ser la de antes y el equipo de
france 24 estuvo en ese país en la
capital jartúm para reportarlo
el distrito de iza en los alrededores de
jartúm es una de las partes más pobres
de la capital sudanesa es también el
hogar de una importante comunidad
cristiana
igual que muchos otros en sudán están
preocupados por los disturbios en el
país
es terrible para nosotros como sudaneses
ver que nuestra sangre se vierta tan
fácilmente ver que la gente muere por
estar pidiendo paz y una vida mejor es
una vergüenza que estemos temerosos de
perder lo ganado en los últimos tiempos
el sentimiento de paz y libertad que
habíamos comenzado a sentir hoy tenemos
9 no encontrar la paz y del sombrío en
certero futuro que afronta sudando
cerca del lugar otra iglesia comparte la
misma ansiedad
bajo el régimen de omar al bashir los
cristianos fueron discriminados y sus
iglesias fueron destruidas
la iglesia queda un poco más abajo fue
destruida empezábamos aquí bajo el sol
durante meses las autoridades el antiguo
régimen lo destruyó no pudimos luchar
por ellos la gente en el poder hace lo
que quiere tenemos miedo de que los
militares restauran el viejo régimen
durante la revolución de 2019 mejoró
sustancialmente la vida de los
cristianos aunque no alcanzaron la
igualdad esta mujer continúa dando la
batalla para preservar las pocas
conquistas que se ganaron
me movilizó como todos los sudaneses
queremos un estado civil y democrático
en donde todo el mundo tenga sus
derechos sin importar su religión que
todo el mundo tenga acceso a los
servicios básicos
los cristianos de ciudad esperan poder
continuar practicando su fe en libertad
como cualquier creyente de otra fe
esperan poder dar un futuro mejor a sus
hijos
netflix escogió a kenia para lanzar su
primera versión de prueba gratuita esta
permitirá un acceso limitado a los
contenidos de la plataforma de streaming
y por ahora estará disponible únicamente
para los dispositivos android así la
compañía busca comprender qué impacto
puede tener en posibles nuevos clientes
en un mercado en plena ebullición y
netflix no es el único gigante que busca
instalarse con fuerza en el mercado de
kenia un país cuyo ecosistema
tecnológico es conocido como el silicón
sabana el siguiente es un reportaje de
los discos y bastian con hoy
billy se ha estado conectando a netflix
de forma gratuita durante dos días el
servicio de telefonía ofrece la
posibilidad de visualizar en vídeos sin
pagar el objetivo atraer nuevos clientes
kenianos
de decidir descargar la aplicación para
ver cómo son los documentales en netflix
ofrecen actualizar si desea ver más que
documentales
de próximo en 3d de bufanda
aproximadamente 22 millones de kenianos
utilizan internet el 97% de ellos a
través de sus teléfonos móviles lo que
convierte el país en un mercado
prometedor atraídos gigantes de la
tecnología como facebook y microsoft se
han asentado ahí
hace unos años no se podía convencer ni
a facebook ni a google para que se
instalaran en áfrica hasta que empezamos
a invertir en infraestructura y lo ven
como un mercado ellos siguen en el
mercado
de markets
the market las empresas también quieren
incrementar su influencia en el campo de
la formación creando escuelas privadas
el objetivo es formar a los jóvenes
kenianos en las últimas tecnologías como
si estuvieran estudiando en silicon
valley si trae a alguien del extranjero
debe capacitar lo el tiempo suficiente
para que comprenda cómo funcionan las
cosas el talento local comprende los
desafíos que enfrenta y el tipo de
problemas que están tratando de resolver
entonces es mucho más fácil trabajar con
ellos le aportan más valor por ejemplo
si es una organización acción que busca
formar un equipo de desarrollo estas
inversiones podrían dar grandes futuros
google y la corporación financiera
internacional estiman que para el 2025
el continente podría beneficiarse del
mercado de la tecnología por una suma de
180 mil millones por año
gracias por acompañarnos en esta nueva
emisión de corresponsales nos damos cita
la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 y 324 puntocom
[Aplausos]